authorities in indonesia and east timor
say as many as a hundred people have
been killed in flash floods and
landslides triggered by a tropical
cyclone
heavy winds and torrential rain pounded
a cluster of eastern indonesian islands
as well as
neighboring east timor emergency teams
are struggling to reach
some of the affected areas
a human chain to escape the raging
waters
rainstorms have triggered landslides and
overflowing dams
leaving small communities inundated
rescue workers use whatever resources
are available to bring survivors to
safety
[Applause]
the water has risen up to my head and
it's still not stopping we need help
right away
your village is cut off yes the water
has reached the second floor
the military police and disaster
agencies are helping coordinate the
emergency response
indonesia's president has offered his
condolences to the dead and called for
vigilance
i urge everyone to follow the directions
of local authorities
regarding the danger of floods and
landslides due to extreme rainfall
in neighboring east timor government
offices were beset by the storm's
effects
as for the moment we are cleaning the
mud because of the flood that happened
in the vicinity of the presidential
palace
rescue efforts in both countries have
been slowed by damaged bridges and roads
and a lack of heavy equipment the
remoteness of some affected areas is
also complicating operations to fully
assess the damage
let's cross straight over to indonesia's
capital now where dw correspondent
pritiya kusuma patri
is monitoring developments for us victor
what is the latest on the flooding there
in
eastern indonesia and east timor
yeah at least 60 people were killed
after a flashlight and landslides
swept parts if east or something got a
province in the neighboring
terminalistic
as official warns of more extreme
weather events
in the upcoming days and the death
though is expected to rise
as the disaster relief officials are
still struggle to
access the you know the worst hit areas
and according to the officials there are
at least 42 people they are still
missing
but this number is very dynamic and
would definitely change
and across the region the scare
residents have flocked to temporary
shelters
and taken refuge at what was left of
their homes
and there are at least 250 people were
evacuated from the
flagpole stricken areas and but the
evacuees are spread out and there are
hundreds in
each sub-district and and many others
are staying at home
but they are definitely need the you
know the the the supply the aid the food
the
medicine and the blanket i wanted to ask
you about that because some of the
reflected areas are quite remote how
difficult is it to get aid in to those
areas
yeah the mod and the continued extra
weather have made it difficult for the
uh
the rescue team and the search team to
you know to find the trap survivors
and the mod has washed over the homes
the bridges the roads
and the strong ways have prevented the
rescue team to
from accessing the the hardest hit areas
and also the pounding range
challenged efforts to find any survivors
and
at the head of east um flores disaster
agency
said that suspect that many are still
buried
but it's not very clear how many people
are still missing but right now the
locals
are trying to deploy the heavy equipment
to try to reopen the the roads
now we're at the end of the monsoon
season
is the flooding we're seeing right now
seasonal or are is is the flooding we're
seeing a result of just the seasonal
weather or is it the result perhaps also
of other factors
well the region of east glories have
been devastated by
intensified rainfall caused by the two
cyclone
but you know the the fatal landslides
and um
the flashlight are actually common in
southeast asia archipelago especially
during the rainy season like this but
the according to the environmentalists
you know the disaster like this the
landslide the you know
the flash flood are often caused by a
deforestation but
we'll be keeping a close watch on this
ritu thank you very much that was dw
correspondent preeta kusuma putri
in jakarta